اضراب كبير يشل فرنسا محطه القطارات
والمترو هذه تكاد تخلو من المسافرين لان
قطع النقل هو ابرز القطاعات التي تشارك في
هذا الاضراب بالاضافه الى قطاعات التعليم
والسكك الحديديه والطاقه معطل انتاج
الكهربائي واوقف عمليه نقل الوقود من
المصافي الى المحطات لكن مشهد خلو وسائل
النقل من المسافرين والمؤسسات من الموظفين
كان مختلفا جدا في الخارج
بها الفرنسيون الى الشارع للاحتجاج على
رفع سن التقاعد وايضا ارتفاع الاسعار وترد
الاوضاع المعيشيه هي موجه ثانيه من اصل
ثلاث موجات للاضراب والتظاهر دعت اليها 8
نقابات والاحزاب اليسا مجتمعه ما يضع
الرئيس الفرنسي امام تحدي جديد مع الشارع
يقول الرجل الاول في الحزب الاشتراكي انهم
سيكملونه حتى النهايه
تحرك ضخم جدا وهدى دليل على تشكل حركه
شعبيه لن تتوقف ستستمر هذه الحركه حتى
تتراجع الحكومه وتسحب هذا المشروع تظاهرات
الموجه الثانيه شهدت زياده في زخم
المشاركه وقالت النقابات ان نصف مليون نزل
الى شوارع العاصمه بين مقدرت الشرطه
اعدادهم بنحو
87.000.000 الاستخبارات الفرنسيه توقعت
مشاركه جماعات يساريه عنيفه صدقه التوقعات
ووقعت صدمات محدوده لكن سرعان ما عدا
الهدوء واستانف المتظاهرون تحركهم
وتكون هناك طرق اخرى للتحرك لان الحكومه
لا تنصت الى الحركه الاجتماعيه في الشارع
لكن رغم كل هذا الغضب لا تبدي الحكومه
اهتماما بالعدول عن هذا القانون وتقول
انها منفتحه على نقاش بعض البنود لكن رفع
سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما ستظل مساله غير
قابله للنقاش فات الدهوك العربيه